I actually got interested in epidemiology and public health back when
I was an undergraduate in Wisconsin an
I was a science journalist.
My daughter is almost three and lately I've been asking her what do you want to do when
you grow up and she said she says now "I want to be a research doctor like Mommy."
And, "So well what do you want to research?" and she says "Babies like like like baby
Owen," her little brother. I got interested
in transplantation when I was a public
health student here at Emory. I had a
really fantastic mentor, Bill McClellan
who was a nephrologist and an
epidemiologist, and he really introduced
me to the field of kidney disease and to
transplantation, and really inspired me
to want to do more in the transplant
world. We want to be able to improve
equity in access to transplantation. As
an epidemiologist I'm striving for
trying to collect better data to report
on these differences with the hope that
eventually there are no differences in
access to transplantation and there's
equality in transplant access across the
country. Emory Transplant Center is
phenomenal and I feel so lucky that I am
working here alongside some of the best
surgeons and nephrologists and others.
I think I want my legacy to be just that
I made some difference in people's lives.
The patients who are willing to donate a
kidney to help save a life are truly
amazing individuals. I think it's so
inspirational when I see the flag raised
for when I know someone has donated an
organ. For me it does have a lot of
personal significance because I've had
family members who have been touched by transplant. but it also it just
illustrates I think the power of altruism and how much that helps someone
else to save a life.